o alvo da ação é parte do ciclo
menstrual em que o ovário liberam óvulo
maduro ou óvulos dentro do várias
centenas de milhares de folículos cada
folículo é uma bola oca de células
imaturas um óvulo imaturo no centro o
ciclo menstrual normal de 28 dias começa
no primeiro dia de sangramento menstrual
durante os primeiros sete dias do ciclo
alguns folículos começam a crescer ao
mesmo tempo estes folículos amadurecidos
secreta um hormônio estrogênio na
corrente sanguínea para preparar a
parede do útero para a gravidez por
volta do dia 7 todos os folículos param
de crescer e começam a se degenerar com
exceção de um este folículo dominante
continua a crescer ea nutrir o óbvio em
desenvolvimento dentro dele
por volta do dia 12 o folículo secreta
uma grande quantidade de estrogênio no
sangue quando o estrógeno atingir o
hipotálamo ea glândula pituitária do
cérebro a parte anterior ou frontal da
glândula pituitária liberam uma grande
quantidade de hormônio luteinizante na
corrente sanguínea
por volta de 14 dias o hormônio
luteinizante faz com que o folículo
passe por um surto de crescimento
repentino pouco antes da ovulação óvulo
se desprende do interior do folículo o
folículo saliente libera substâncias
químicas fazendo com que as duas trompas
de falópio se aproximem e rodei um
folículo o folículo encha até que ele se
abre
liderando o volume o líquido do folículo
na cavidade abdominal por conseguinte as
filhas pequenas projeções no final da
trompa de falópio passam rapidamente
através do local da ovulação e recolhem
os óvulos cílios microscópicos na
superfície das inglês levam o óvulo até
a entrada da trompa de falópio dentro
das paredes da trompa de falópio as
contrações musculares empurram o óvulo
em direção ao útero após a ovulação
óvulo vive entre 12
24 horas portanto para que uma mulher
engravide o óvulo deve ser fecundado por
um espermatozóide durante esse período
se não for fecundado o óvulo se dissolve
e é removido juntamente com as paredes
do útero durante a menstruação
ah